Eric Davis Jason how's it going dude
it's so good I'm so thrilled to have you
here as you know I'm a longtime fan and
just appreciate your mind and the
rigorous dazzling way in which you
approach the great mysteries of
consciousness and I just often turn to
your writing when I want to find the
language to articulate something
ineffable wonderful I like to that's
that's the space I like to it you know
you are you are one of the virtuosos of
the articulation of the ineffable and
you know so many of the of the stuff
you've written about altered states of
consciousness you know these are spaces
that are characterized by their
ineffability I mean people say they have
mystical experiences and one of the
hallmarks of mystical experiences that
it is fundamentally ineffable or
paradoxical and it just can't be
language you had to be there and I can
appreciate that maybe empirical language
doesn't always do justice to the
experience unless you're Eric Davis but
I think that what you do beautifully is
that you can bring a sort of rigor to
these domains and languaging to these
domains while acknowledging what is
fundamentally poetic and what were the
limitations of empiricism lie in trying
to assimilate or understand or bring
into language or bring into time and
into coherence that which is
fundamentally the other side of the of
the lines and and and beyond the
day-to-day yeah well the word beyond is
key I mean that's something to talk
about and in high weirdness in
particular I sort of say you know
throughout this this this book I'm going
to refer to the beyond or the outside
sometimes the other which is a little
different because sometimes the other
has a sort of personality that the other
the beyond and the outside don't mm-hmm
but I explicitly say I'm gonna leave
these things sort of undefined because
they're more like gestures mm-hm or
they're more like attitudes
acknowledgments you know even even a
little bit of a bow towards these zones
and just and just proceed as if we all
recognize that there are things that are
outside our understanding outside our
language and that we can get close to
them or engage them and counter them
that's a term I like a lot of encounter
because it doesn't mean you understand
them it doesn't mean you've grasped them
but but there's still some point of
contact and whether you can entirely
language that or not it doesn't almost
matter to me it's more about proceeding
with a certain humility yet however
either how however carefully you use
empirical language or however
evocatively use poetic language yeah the
neither of them are really gonna totally
cut the mustard and that's just the
condition we're in a condition
ultimately I I celebrate and I think a
lot of people that that's you know they
resist that they don't want to so you
think you think everything is an
approximation or an attempt at
representing an attempt at Co hearing
and bringing into language but you're
saying even and even empirical accounts
of the world can never be fully 100%
yeah I'm taste sure what they describe
sure absolutely no the representation
falls apart in in in a more in a larger
encounter yeah that with something
that's ultimately a mystery you know and
that's one thing I've been thinking
about recently you know I don't know
it's always I've always just trust the
idea you can kind of divide people into
two camps but I do think you can divide
certainly intellectuals into camps and
one of them one camp is the one that
really believes that they're so invested
in articulation and analysis and
understanding and the development of
knowledge and if there's scientists you
know in creating shared bodies of
knowledge that move farther and farther
into the unknown and
and bring it into the known they're so
invested in that that they don't even
really believe in that it's that we
should talk about something like the
great mystery of things that that's sort
of like a gross
it's almost repulsive like the whole
point is it's it's not a mystery if you
understand it there are things we don't
know but that we'll know them eventually
yeah
and then I think there's a lot of us
probably people who are more interested
in poetry and spirituality and music and
aesthetics and things where you're like
no there's a there's a big mystery at
the heart of this whole thing like why
is it here in the first place yeah you
know what what is what is consciousness
what's inspiring me and while I'm really
interested in analysis and knowledge and
different forms of under attempting to
understand the situation
I very much remain sort of in awe of the
the unfolding mystery and I don't
believe I believe it's endless yeah
since it's endless we might as well
begin developing a relationship with
that with the endless with the outside
with the beyond and let that yeah
welcome in but grappling with the
so-called unknowable causes a lot of
existential disquiet particularly in the
Western rationalist mindset you explored
this brilliantly in your book techno
Sasan I first discovered you myth magic
and mysticism in the age of information
you know on the one hand it's a book
about technology and and technology's
capacity to help us overcome problems
and creating scientific instruments that
can help us know the world and why are
the world and and and and cognate eyes
the world with artificial intelligence
and all of these dazzling Silicon Valley
technologies on the one hand and then
you also illustrate how underneath this
hyper rational engineering mathematical
understanding of the world are the the
the mystery still is hidden underneath
you know the yearning for transcendence
the yearning for immortality the the
yearning for telepathy and omniscience
and all these things are there they are
you know there may be like like on the
shadow side but there
they are nonetheless and so you think
this is a fundamentally human thing that
it's it's just gonna follow us no matter
no matter how successful the Western
rationalist materialist understanding or
account of things is that the human
mystery is gonna follow everywhere I
don't know about everywhere I mean I'm
comfortable I'm enough of a pluralist
that I can believe that that some people
really inhabit inhabit a kind of fully
rationalized world where they their
emotions how they deal with with
problems how they deal with the unknown
how they make decisions it can be so
rationalized that in some sense they're
just sort of operating in this kind of
efficiency productivity knowledge-based
mode and for them there may be are no
real mysteries there's just problems
that haven't been solved yet and that's
their kind of existential world I think
that is you know a very unusual way to
be compared to the way most people are
where we still are in these these
mysteries and ambiguities these patterns
of desire and imagination where you know
our dreams can still knock us on our ass
and we wake up the next day and we're
like wow you know like I can I'm
different now because I dreamt that yeah
I wondered this God or I was flying or
you know the you know the the beavers
were talking to me or whatever the the
sort of the imaginal experience is it
still really changes most of us one of
the things that I struggle with is
grappling with what feels like different
types of truth and you know I guess I
find some comfort in you know when the
Greeks talk about Chronos and Kairos so
that there's two modes of describing the
experience of time there is sort of
mechanized cognition consensus time
empirical time and I used the example of
like a movie so a movie theater might be
in Chronos empirically 2 hours and 20
minutes running time from the outside
but Kairos which is the realm of the
timeless consciousness that exists
outside of time dream consciousness
liminal consciousness that you can be
watching a movie and from the inside
have an experience that is completely
timeless completely transformative in
front
occurs way beyond two hours and 20
minutes of external running time or this
notion that mythology is false from the
outside or true from the inside or that
art is the lie but the lie that reveals
the truth or that sometimes fiction is
more truthful than reality you know
Jordan Peterson has become very famous
for grappling with some of these
questions around religious truth their
archetypal truth you know Carl Jung also
was interested in archetypes and these
realms and so people are saying yeah but
what do you mean like well how can
something be archetype fully true like
is it true or is it not true is a myth
true I'm like well it's true but did it
happen well not necessarily you know is
where do you stand on those two sides
those are great questions I actually
want to go back to the time example yeah
because you you used the word mode on
top of there's some different modes of
time and I sure I like that kind of
thinking I like modal thinking uh-huh
one of the the authors that I that I
really draw a lot from for high
weirdness and it was also who also plays
an important role in tech gnosis is this
French sociologist of science and
philosopher Bruno Latour and he wrote a
very he wrote a very interesting book
called the modes of existence on the
modes of existence and his argument is
that things exist in different modes we
are in a multiplicity of modes of
reality and so you know an obvious
example is the example that he uses that
it's important for my book is like
Sherlock Holmes has a certain quality of
agreed upon reality a certain kind of
consistency as a sort of a certain kind
or mode of existence and what he calls
is that this is the mode of fictions so
within the mode of fictions you know
Sherlock Holmes you got it you got to
give them some some ontological wait
wait right yeah now from another
perspective in perspective of a
different mode that's not really that's
there
adequate and Latour doesn't pretend like
he has all the modes wired in fact what
he sort of encourages us is to recognize
that the world is a multiplicity of
modes of existence and so when you to go
back to your example yes the movie
theatres is an objective space and if
someone has a measurement device we're
gonna get 2 hours and 20 minutes and
then that's part of an economy of like
how then have we yeah the next one
bubble tonight a ticket it starts at a
time it ends at a certain time all that
yeah yeah and right there is this sort
of evocative mode of fiction that allows
within it different kinds of experience
in different modes of time let's say to
to exact o exists and when you when you
just go you know if it's the case that
reality is multiple fundamentally yeah
multiple then a lot of these problems
kind of disappeared cuz you're like yes
and yes and well yes and what comes to
mind then is then that we avoid problems
as long as we can draw lines between the
modes just like we have a separation
between church and state that's would be
the separation between the empirical and
the poetic or the literal and the mythic
because state would be the movie is two
hours and 20 minutes running time it's
rated R you go to this movie theater at
this time you don't turn your phone on
during it those are the rules of the
state church would be that movie is the
truth of how I want to live my life and
now everybody should follow me no no no
no that movie told you the truth about
how you should live your life or as long
as you're not hurting anybody else and
not imposing that truth than anybody
else we're fine and you can like take
this out of the example of the movie
theater and bring it to everything you
know you could bring it to the
psychedelic Renaissance you know like
objectively well okay material molecules
that we ingest that in fMRI scans which
is an instrument we use to look inside
the brain it looks like a part of the
brain that we think controls the
autobiographical sense of self gets kind
of dissipated and that by shutting that
down different parts of the brain talk
to each other and it seems to do
according to the neuroscientist the guy
from Robin Carhartt Harris it's an
effect akin to shaking the snowglobe
from like obsessive looping patterns
that don't serve you anymore that are so
often characterized in in issues with
depression and anxiety and OCD and all
this stuff and so that's like an
objective state account of why
psychedelics might work the experience
of shaking the snowglobe in the brain
you know dampening the default mode
network for five to six hours in a safe
environment allows the person to see
themselves and see the world from a
distinctly different vantage point and
that maybe allowed them to finally
dispense or metabolize these patterns of
thought that have been so in groove that
don't serve them anymore that's state
separate that from church church is I
[ __ ] trip walls
I saw the universe I became one with
everything I realize that death is an
illusion I that we're all eternal and
now I'm gonna like sitting cacao
ceremonies and wear funny hats and like
all is good in the world but the problem
is when that person has that experience
a church experience and then wants to
become the shaman and wants to tell
everybody else what to believe about
their own their own interior experience
because this is the problem nowadays you
know saying you're entitled to your
opinion but not to your own facts may be
a better way of saying that is you are
entitled to your own poetic facts but
you're not entitled to your own
empirical facts you're entitled to your
own church but not to your own state you
know for the most part yeah I mean one
way the problem that is like is
recognizing which mode you're in for any
given situation or any given problem and
what are the appropriate tools for that
mode yes and that's where people have a
lot of trouble because I think it's
partly because people aren't really
embracing this multiplicity right
approach because it's sort of scary
because you know people go that's just
post-modernism you think everything is
relative oh it's you know and then it's
the problem of relativism that's not
quite right it's not quite right because
there are better and worse tools to
bring to any particular mode yes
and you know if you if you overtime an
experience and through pedagogy and
through tradition and through innovation
and through new tools and all of those
things we come up with this why we have
this huge tool belt
but we're very poor at recognizing what
tools are appropriate for what modes or
even acknowledging that there are
different modes yeah and it's
interesting because you know I find
somehow and I have a lot of friends who
who fall into one or the other you know
they're the ones that are just allergic
to anything Church like or spiritual
language like that mode and they're like
fully Western and empirical and then I
have others that are like how can I live
without the spiritual dimension of life
and science is arrogant and Sciences
scientism and so on is over and for me
somehow intuitively I've never had a
problem with compartmentalizing the
different modes and that kind of
compartmentalization it just kind of
makes sense to me you know it seemed
from Dead Poets Society when Robin
Williams is the thing huddle up huddle
up and he says you know engineering
science mathematics these are noble
pursuits necessary to sustain life but
poetry beauty love this is what we stay
alive for and ultimately poetry truth
love or at least poetic truth
these are Kairos these are church you
know but state should be engineering
science mathematics the noble pursues
necessary to sustain life the area is
the division or Ursula Le Guin
she says science describes accurately
from the outside
poetry describes accurately from the
inside science explicate s-- poetry
implicates one of the things that you're
also talking about there is you're not
just making distinction between science
and and other human pursuits but you're
using this balance of state and church
and I think that's really key because
one of the ways of seeing what's
happening to politics now and I don't
want to dive into the whole shebang but
but just to make some meta comments
about it is that I remember very
distinctly a friend of mine he was
British it's kind of a British attitude
although they they're not living by it
at all any more than we are
in the States but he said you know the
thing about about politics and
politicians is that it should be really
boring mm-hmm it should be boring right
it should sort of instruments of
attempting to deal with you know
different demands and navigate to the
best you can at will given the situation
that it should be kind of procedural
pragmatic not poetic that's right but
what's happening now is that the poetry
and it's not very good poetry no it's
not but it is poetry is now in the heart
of the state it's it's so we have these
I would follow like circus poetry
reality show poetry but it's still
poetry yeah I'm [ __ ] fiction with
languages yeah you know it's not good
poetry but it but it is like calling up
you know old archetypes it's like you
can see the archetypes and in conspiracy
theory is another example of this
conspiracy theory is where you take the
the operations of historical thinking
right that involved you know empirical
facts dominant discussions you know
including the possibility that these are
not all correct and there are things
we're not acknowledging but that's all
part of sure conventional historical
thinking so you take the engine of
historical thinking and then you you you
inject all these let's call them you
know poems or fictions or visions or
this internal realm stuff that's right
where you have you know good and evil
fighting battles at the end of time yeah
and that's all and so then they're
mushed together and distributed and with
the collapse of authority very just are
raging I mean oh my god that stuff is
that's hope that's the [ __ ] problem
that we're having today you know these
these the the the porousness between the
modes is making everybody really [ __ ]
confused you know I there's another
quote this guy you know Alain de Botton
out of the UK I love him and he had this
line that I loved where he said you know
we're by a poem maybe less accurate and
I'm paraphrasing a poem is less accurate
and describing the details of an event
than a journalist's
count of said event the poem may
nevertheless reveal truths of a deeper
sort so that the journalistic account of
it is more of a naive realism but that
the poem reveals truth of a deeper sort
beyond the literal grid but then fine
but then we should distinguish the grids
you know church and state the literal
grid and the poetic grid the science
grid and the Missal poetic grid you know
and I'm I live for the mythopoetic you
know I live for the [ __ ] timeless the
art I make are meant to explore
beautiful ideas but I put a big [ __ ]
parentheses around it and I'm like I'm
making art I'm not calling anything
other than art you know and and the
importance of that is because I when I
play in the mythopoetic I distinctly
want to be outside of the default world
and as long as that that line is super
crisp I can just be a playful and
creative person versus a psychotic
person exactly right yeah yeah no it's
true it's it's really respecting the
difference between the modes and that
was something that was always that like
you it was just my temperament like I
you know I I have my father as a
scientist I thought I was going to study
science I study a lot of mathematics I
most a lot of my good friends are
technical people or hardcore
materialists people they're not I don't
hang I mean I you know I know people who
are spiritual practitioners I know some
religious people but you know a lot of
my friends are from that side so but I
was always very not even just
comfortable but drawn towards
appreciating these different modes and
for like seeing how they relate but also
how there's a distinction between them
you know and and to see that we're
always negotiating you know individually
and culturally between these the
mythopoetic and the sort of scientific
that's right and I think but again here
I think you're right what's happen one
of the things that's happening now is
just that though it's so porous that
it's like all the the phantasms are now
loose in the consensus reality that that
had been more generated through these
empirical
Oracle processes and in a way that's
what I was talking about in tech gnosis
is you you know you have these rational
technologies you build these systems
based on them you think you're kind of
chasing away religion as you install
these new systems because after all the
Telegraph looks better than the in the
mystical invocation so now everyone's
gonna go well I guess the guys who are
making the Telegraph kind of have their
they're the ones who get to say what
reality is but you know then the stuff
slips slips in again and it's not
unfortunately it's not just a yen for
wonder or yen for transcendence or for
you know the big cosmic view or their
overview or whatever it's also like good
and evil and so once you have evil then
you have demons and you have demons
manipulating and then you have things
behind the thing and then you you know
and then there's another whole element I
think that's happening is just the earth
you know this the the material world is
also sort of losing its consistency as
we enter into a period of climate change
so it's not just about the climates
going to become more challenging in all
these political ecological you know
physical ways and there's you know
that's a whole that's just you know
that's the elephant in the room but it's
also that the the climate that the the
weather that is our weather is shifting
and so it's fundamentally pulling again
this sense of some kind of consistent
consensus some some kind of agreed-upon
reality and as that happens I think
there's also a sense of the the kind of
non rational factors of being on a
planet become more and more evident as
well hmm this is this is endlessly
interesting to me especially because on
the one hand I think there is an aspect
of a human character that just
existentially needs to believe in cosmic
specialists right nose cough cow said
man needs to believe there's something
indestructible within himself or
Dostoevsky talked about the importance
of blasting new tunnels between the mind
and the other like we want to feel part
of a larger whole and on the one hand
well we are right we're made of atoms
that were cooked in the furnaces of star
you know and Neil deGrasse Tyson says
that makes him feel big not small so
that's that's like an empirical truth
but also on a poetic level we just want
to feel like we matter you know
existentially we are [ __ ] mortal
beings we can conceive of the infinite
but we watch ourselves age every single
day and the cognitive dissonance is that
is horrific and so we need meaning and
so we want a meaning that has its own
ontological grounding we don't like the
idea that we're creating the meaning
because then we cut up in the idea that
we're just deluding ourselves but this
is a fundamental problem enough that
these fracturing that are happening now
where we don't have like the simple lie
or the simple character as a vital lie
of culture and religion whether it was
westernized or not but that gave you a
set way of things that's getting
increasingly fractured and porous and
frazzled and so it's leading to this
so-called epidemic of mental distress
and [ __ ] a more people committing
suicide now than are dying from natural
disasters and armed conflict combined
and this is a United Nations number Wow
more people than armed conflict the
natural disasters combined are killing
themselves nowadays
extraordinary and so it's like okay so
we need to figure out like what we
believe and how we believe what we
believe and what we think about what we
believe and on what ontological layer it
exists as truth you know what are the
myths that are true from the inside what
false from the outside and not to
confuse those myths versus the facts
that are true from the outside and from
the inside no matter how you look at
them but this is where now psychotherapy
is deploying a sort of Renaissance who
are rediscovering the material molecules
that start to play with with these
domains better or for worse and this is
interesting because you have grappled
with this because I'm gonna read you
your own quote because on the one hand
we know now that in controlled
environments whether johns hopkins
university studies nyu steven roth
merlin Griffis they're deploying
psychedelic mushrooms giving it to
people who have profound existential
anxiety that's not responding to
traditional medication and a single
guided trip if it ticks all the boxes of
a mystical experience the person is
cured of their anxiety
so that's like objective this experience
this molecule a particular experience
the person had and they no longer meet
the criteria of depression or anxiety
and they engage more with the world so
that's all quantifiable and true that's
enough to legalize these substances
that's it has epistemic value so to
speak but then there's the fact that
when people describe what they
experienced it we can't fit it into our
Western models of understanding of the
world I emerged with the cosmos I rose
up outside my body my spirit left and
but on the one hand the researchers are
like if we want to get this [ __ ]
legalized we don't we don't want to go
there we don't want to ask about the
truth from the inside we only care about
the truth from the outside of the
measurable quantifiable improvements in
people's lives and you this is your line
and then you can unpack it for us if you
like we are sweeping such sublimity x'
you know the accounts of people merging
with God and there was like a Dalek
experience under the rug of side effects
or so-called toxic side effects the
researchers and the partners in the
industry are sidestepping or wanna
sidestep the remarkable paradox the
psychedelic substances present to
brain-based reductionists psychedelics
are material molecules that frequently
occasion experiences that look and feel
for all the world like the sort of
mystical or religious raptures whose
unfolding cognitive content calls into
question the strict materialism in other
words these reductionist researchers of
powerful psychedelics must still squirm
before God or at least before the
experiential states that recall the
ecstatic reports of mystics so I always
wanted to say that in a microphone idea
right that here these scientists
buttoned up wearing a suit have to
convince the FDA that these that these
molecules you give it to a person in a
controlled environment with therapy and
then we can quantifiably measure that
these people are better and no longer
meet the criteria for PTSD or depression
or whatever but we're not going to go
into what the purse purse the
first-person narrative of their
experience was
this is what's so interesting is like
here we are going back to the separation
of church and state or inside and
outside empirical truth versus poetic
truth it is the experience of poetic
truth and rapture that seems to cause
healing that has a reality believe
through effect and has then empirical
quantifiable quantifiable left brain
state measurable healings how
interesting is that's totally amazing
it's really really interesting and and
and you know in a way the the proper
pragmatic response is to sort of just
bracket those experiences and say I mean
because they do acknowledge them to the
extent that they have a checklist that's
like you know the mystical experience
report checklist this has been used for
decades you know it is based on
someone's interpretation of mysticism
which is very questionable from certain
other angles you know there's there's a
whole thing to be said about why is it
that the unitive mystical experience
that all is one and the sense of clarity
and unity and sort of impersonal
grandeur why is that the apex of the
triangle what about you know there's
there's a you know a whole immense
continents of mystical experiences that
involve the encounter with God
you know the encounter with a loving
knowing person and that personality or a
person that you have a relationship with
of love and the most profound
relationship in your life and that's
that's not just a couple that's huge
that's whole tradition so what do we do
with those and then moving over it what
do we do with like indigenous encounters
with spirits of the forest and who
aren't that they're not the great God on
the top of the mountaintop and they're
not impersonal unity they're like I've
our relationships with kind of trickster
characters who may have something to
tell you and they know it's a whole
other domain now Pan's Labyrinth yeah
are we gonna exactly are we gonna say
well that's low on the on the triangle
and the ones who think it's God they
just haven't quite seen what we've seen
and that's the thing is if you if you
look at this
the measure the mystical measure that
Johns Hopkins uses to tick off the box
so someone can come in and go they had
how was their mushroom experience it was
all right they didn't get ineffable they
didn't get no wedeck so you know maybe
it's and and they claim that the more
you check off these boxes the more
powerful and transformative the
experience is okay great maybe that's
true but if you ask why are these the
boxes yeah it's a very historical
question and some people are like you
know maybe for at least for some people
those aren't the the the the the most
important kinds of experiences you can
have and does this really account for
the way indigenous people approach
reality the way that profoundly
believing Christians or Muslims approach
reality yeah and so even that is kind of
like gets us sort of immediately into
these sort of murky waters but I think
that I mean it's just gonna be very
interesting to see because as this stuff
gets assimilated which it clearly is
going to because there is this mental
health crisis yeah because they haven't
come up with anything since SSRIs in the
early 1980s okay and though and those
they barely would even pass see they
might not even pass a placebo test today
the way they barely did back then so we
don't have much and there's a crisis as
you say I mean it's no joke so anything
is good and another little tricky factor
that might my friend Mike J who write
who's a historian of drugs as well as
historian of psychiatry has been really
clear about communicating he just wrote
a terrific book about mescaline and he
talks a little bit about this there but
is that if you look through the history
of 20th century psychiatry it's it's you
find these hyped moments we're like oh
my god we finally figured out a way to
deal with these huge deep problems of
human sex I calls you like things like
lobotomies or electroshock therapy or
Thorazine
you know and it's not just this is the
tricky part
it's not just that well there was a lot
of hype around those things and then we
realized down the line that
see they only do so much good although
electroshocks coming back and there's
some reason to think that that's good
and that it uh but what's trickier is
that we're dealing with this weird realm
between mind and matter where there's an
inside in your terms as well as an
outside yeah and so different somewhat
different rules apply and it may be the
case that when you introduce a new
therapy into society and there's a new
therapy and now we're all doing the new
therapy but you actually do get more
results it really does look like a
panacea like oh my god we got it and
then as the years go by if she comes
assimilated into the system and it's a
sure same guys you know doing the thing
but it doesn't work as well anymore you
know and that might have something to do
with the way that a lot of psychological
tests when they retest them now and
we're psychological experiments they
seem to get a robust response and then
you know five years down the line ten
years down the line somebody else some
of the university does it again doesn't
work that is epidemic in social
psychology right now so we don't know
what the heck's going on at all and so
we get to see that happen with
psychedelics now and I think that's the
biggest the biggest you know my
intuition is that for now as far as
passing legislation to allow people to
have legal access to these treatments
and controlled environments without
window dressing the interior experience
you know let people have their interior
experience that's the only way we pass
this into law where we we ignore the
contents of the experience as long as
the person is better there are these
cognitive philosophers out of Australia
one of them is called Chris les abhi I
don't know if I send you that article in
a on it was called psychedelics work by
violating our expectations of mind and
world and these guys their cognitive
philosophers so they are materialists
they believe that consciousness resides
in a material brain and therefore that
all the stuff that happens during a
psychedelic experience is originating in
a material brain but they still believe
that psychedelic experience can even
though they call into question strict
materialism that
doesn't matter because what they believe
is that what matters is their epistemic
value in that if a person has an
experience right where they encounter in
the words of these guys an experience of
knowledge by acquaintance versus
knowledge by a description that then has
quantifiable better like results where
the person is engaging with the world
more because they're not anxious or
depressed anymore which means they do
more things in the world and then we've
effectively treated them and that's all
that matters and and this was very
interesting because you know they say
that the diseases of anxiety you know
the mental health diseases of anxiety of
depression of OCD but they all share
this similar rigidity of thought you
know there so if we have the famous
lenses of perception or the lenses of
expectations you know we don't see the
world as it is we see the world as we
are and we see with our lenses and
through our lenses but we don't always
see the lenses themselves so they talk
about the example of somebody who's in
the throngs of a depressive psychosis or
somebody who's really anxious so you can
grab a depressed person like I hate my
life I hate my job it's all hopeless and
I'm like dude like let's just get you on
a plane and go to Cape Town and like
like let's [ __ ] we take you surfing
like you've never surfed let's teach you
how to surf for like a week you know
let's smoke a joint go on safari let's
have you like encounter the elephants
during Golden Hour in the middle of the
Safari let's see what happens because
you assume that you're gonna take
yourself with you wherever you go
because knowledge by description can't
reach somebody who is so blindsided by
their filters of perception at this
moment but that psychedelics can
engender an experience of knowledge by
acquaintance acquaintance is like the
felt experience the poetic experience
where you know your modes of perception
are obliterated in McKenna's quaking and
dilating glory you know it's like you
can't rationalize away in the moment the
profundity or the intensity of these of
the psychedelic experience and so that's
knowledge by acquaintance it's akin to
lifting the depressed person and placing
them somewhere else so by actually
viscerally experiencing another place
from which to plant their feet it seems
to make you aware of your own lenses
that's the line they use it psychedelics
have this magical capacity of taking the
lenses that you see through and with and
making you action
see the lenses and at the moment of true
catharsis and integration is once you've
seen the lenses you can go get rid of
them they don't serve me anymore and
then create new interpretive frameworks
so that it they say sidestep going into
the debate about the metaphysical or
ontological truth of the contents of the
experience because they're like
ultimately what matters is that you had
a profound encounter with a different
way of seeing things that finally
finally dissipated those those rigid
patterns of thinking and I mean I
thought that wasn't interesting I think
that's it great I mean I don't think
it's necessarily helpful to go into the
to the metaphysical questions I think
that there is something strange that
happens if you try to ignore the sacred
dimension that that people experience or
the way that they the way that they
experience it that there's particularly
something strange about the question of
entities to me that's where things get
really interesting so if you have a
impersonal I'm one with the cosmos
moment great but what do you do if you
you're in that space and then suddenly
you're aware that you're actually part
of a panel of entities from around the
cosmos and you're all cities art of
sitting around this cosmic table kind of
looking at each other and recognizing
that that nobody knows what's going on
but we're all kind of in this room
together suddenly there's a quality of
relationship that appears in that and
lots of psychedelic experiences have
these as well as experiences of profound
unity but they're much much more strange
difficult to talk about and that's you
know one of the things the themes in
high weirdness is that these three guys
that I'm talking about Robert Anton
Wilson and Phil okay dick Terence
Mckenna that they all encounter in the
midst of all of these you know different
dimensions and science fictional
operations and rushes of energy they
encounter these sort of entities and
well now what now is there an epistemic
value to that I think there is well it's
like people who think yeah who talk to
aliens that tell them what to do
whatever as long as the aliens are
telling you to be kind to thy neighbor
fine but if the voices in your head are
telling you to school up a shoot up a
schoolyard and that's the problem you
know my problem is when it when soon as
you start talking about entities I start
to worry about what's the difference
between this and a schizophrenic who
hears voices and there's it's very very
difficult to make that distinction I
mean I have James Kent who's a you know
psychedelic longtime psychedelic
researcher and does dos Nation podcast
he just did this withering critique of
psychedelic culture and he in one of his
episodes he talks about how you know
like he tells a story of like these few
nobodies who like took some mushrooms
and one of them ended up like you know
chopping the other guy's heart out with
it with it with this with a knife and
then the cops come and he's all covered
with blood he said no he was a D was a
demon whatever and then you're like okay
well whatever told him that that was the
case whatever spirit went like if you're
gonna say well no that's psychotic right
well where do you draw the line
hundred-percent and my intuition man and
again this this might be because I like
to III I like to entertain wild ideas
but in the end Occam's razor right like
I'm really I'm really the idea of set
and setting and the idea that
psychedelic trips are constructed by
culture set and expectation rings very
true to me
it's so you know a Christian might have
a psychedelic experience and actually
see Jesus an indigenous person might see
the trickster spirits in the forest
because that's kind of the stories they
grew up with that have been seeded into
their subconscious and if psychedelics
are ultimately nonspecific amplifiers of
consciousness or gateways to the
unconscious or patterns of mind and
thought that are disinhibited from the
handshake that we make every day between
our projections and illusions and the
world that we encounter and as long as
that you know when that handshake is is
okay like I can I can sprinkle some
magical thinking on the world that I am
special and I am here to do cool things
and this and that as long as that
handshakes okay with the feedback I'm
receiving then I'm a well-adjusted
person as soon as I'm sprinkling magical
thinking that is in people
with the world that I'm encountering
every day now I start to be a person
that has pathologies some sort or or a
following right crazy person in a genius
the genius has an audience people follow
him and they create a that's when
somebody can lose out of touch you know
they get too famous and too many yes
people around them and they literally
like now have a handshake with a
different encounter but but I want to
get back to the entity thing because I
want to finish my job which is it's not
I want to make clear that I'm not
talking about that there really are
these you know incorporeal until cosmic
intelligence is that we're communicating
yeah what I'm saying is that the the
condition of finding yourself in an AI
thou relationship in psychedelic space
to me indicates another dimension of
healing which relates to to something
else you talked about earlier
particularly talking about with both
depressed people and and anxious people
there's a sense of disconnection from
the world that's right so what does it
mean to be connected to the world what
especially what does it mean to be
connected to the world not in the usual
Western tool using manipulative agent
mode we're like I'm going out in the
world to satisfy my desires and and
achieve power and I'm going to
manipulate the situation or you could
say what do we what is it does it mean
to relate to the world not in that mode
to have the I vow alright so relate
right it's a relational situation so for
me inter subjective the the entity is a
mark of a model of relationality that
applies to completely ordinary
situations our relationships to other
people our relationships to the material
conditions that we actually live in to
them in material institutions but
particularly to the to the planet and to
be able to appreciate that there that
there's a tremendous value in the in the
in the I thou in terms of mutual
responsibilities in terms of thinking in
terms of systems rather than in terms of
human desires alone so that actually
that agent encounter that entity
encounter is kind of like an initiation
into a different way probably relay
that ties us back in and it's not easy
because we're being tied into a
situation that's incredibly challenging
right now it's not like oh I'm you know
oh I'm one with the universe and great
that's happy I guess for you wonderful
but like if I'm one with the planet it's
like the planets like whoa this thing
that people yeah a lot of creatures
whole worlds are dying you know there's
whatever plastic everywhere you know the
whole thing so it's not it's there's
something sobering about it too and I
think that what's happening is that that
that you know the stories the fantasies
the phantasms are so appealing and
there's so much more easy to deal with
then than handling the complexities of
reality that people get sucked into them
but that still that I thou relationship
is a really key doorway towards the kind
of relationality that both allows us to
feel connected to the world but also
allows us to feel responsible for the
world and to recognize that we are
profoundly embedded we're not just solo
Western tool-using
agents who are doing using technology to
get ahead you know that that's such a
dominant mode of experience in our in
our in our reality now so so even even
the crazy stuff I think points towards
things that are profound yeah yeah well
and then and then grappling with the
crazy stuff or experiences that on the
one hand you have undergone but that
fall outside the scope of understanding
or you cannot account for them using the
the normal ways of accounting for
reality than you're used to raises a lot
of questions yeah we're looping around
what we talked about initially because
for me when it when I win one of the
stories I have is like okay my book what
is it about basically that psychedelics
may be healing they may be even sacred
or profound but they're also really
[ __ ] weird and what does that mean it
means we don't know what's going on
you're in a place that it's
uncomfortable it's strange it's a little
bit ominous it seems kind of it's not
just you it's like there's something
about the thing itself that you don't
really get and to me that's a really
important
emotion and and and not just emotional
like a mode of relating to the fact that
there's always more than you can fit
into your system that the world is
larger than any of your maps and models
and that perhaps right now even in
particular we are even though it's
difficult and a lot of people are
running in the opposite direction that
those of us who can take it we need to
expand into increasingly uncomfortable
spaces of recognizing what's going on
including the unfound discomfort of
recognizing that it's so complicated
that there's no way we can understand
what's going on and really to be in that
and I'm increasingly think that one of
the great gifts of psychedelics
particularly you know bigger experiences
is that sometimes you're totally
confused and you learn that actually you
can learn you can manipulative ER in
total confusion but that it's actually
really helpful to become intimate with
total confusion you can't make decisions
from there but you also can't make
decisions adequately if you believe that
your story that you're holding on to to
master the fears of total confusion is
the only way because that's what we're
seeing now everyone's retreating from
the complexity the just the sheer
complexity of our moment into these
stories because it's too terrifying so
but it is too terrifying well but then
then then grab the terror then then part
of psychedelics is is it's it's a terror
show yeah and you get some dark stuff in
there maybe they dissolve perhaps the
necessary ontological ground we need
some mode of someplace from which to
operate from otherwise we can't fetch
water or chop wood I mean it's really
hard one thing is to say you're living
with the mystery when you're just using
a word or you're just saying I don't
know something else is encountering the
incoherent complexity of the mystery and
feel that incoherence viscerally and
then feel like well I'm drowning in a
sea of confusion and that's pretty
[ __ ] scary I'm reminded a lot of you
ever see the movie contact oh yeah Jodie
Foster yeah based on the Carl Sagan book
so I love the end of that film very
much because I watched that film and I
think it's a wonderful meditation
between science and religion you know
Jodie Foster plays Ellie Arroway she's
an astronomer she's a materialist but
she's also wonder junkie so like Sagan
you know she looks at the cosmos with a
sacred awe but she uses mathematics to
understand it you know and then she's
dating the Matthew McConaughey character
who was essentially a priest and he's
just like I can't imagine the world
without God you know and then the sort
of climax of the film for those who
haven't seen it is you know they get a
message from space and it has all this
mathematical equation that they figure
out supposedly from the intelligent
aliens to build a vessel and then it
builds they they build this contraption
that spins and the idea is that it
creates a vortex in space-time and then
the capsule is meant to be dropped
through the vortex and they think that
it's gonna get slingshotted across the
universe
so now Jodie Foster is in it you know
she's filled she's built this thing with
alien technology I mean it's like you
you you have like a cognitive orgasm in
anticipation of what's good she's gonna
find you know and then they drop her
through it and you get that you get the
camera angle from outside the ship and
it shows that it's released into the
vortex but then we cut to her her own
experience and now we're inside the ship
with her she's wearing a handheld or a
head mounted camera and we see her I
guess ultimately her experience and her
experience is that the thing opens a
wormhole she goes to the other side of
the universe freaking witnesses
celestial events meets the aliens who
incarnated as a virtual reality
rendering of her father in her childhood
Beach to tell her everything is gonna be
okay and there's a mystery and mystery
we will never know small steps le which
is what her dad used to tell and then
then we'd cut back to the outside camera
showing that the ship fell right through
the vortex didn't go anywhere
was on camera the whole time except for
a microsecond of interference and now
she is like what year is it I went and
the whole movie up until this point
she's mocked religious people for their
encounters with the mystery and now she
has to sit in front of a panel of
scientists and say I had an experience I
went across the galaxy I met the
as a scientist I have to concede I might
have just bumped my head and
hallucinating the whole thing you have
an inside-outside dichotomy and if the
movie ended there
that would already be a brilliant
frustrating end of the mystery because
you know you're rooting for her you saw
her having the experience you believed
her until you liked her has to concede
hey that sounds like a [ __ ] thing
that she imagined but then the last
scene is they take her head mounted
camera and they're like oh it only
recorded static but then they're like
well that's not the concern that it just
recorded static but that it recorded 15
hours of static even though she only was
she went through that thing in five
seconds so then the director is
basically wink wink saying okay look it
was a wormhole it folded space-time and
[ __ ] can get weird you know relativity
and the warping of space-time could be a
way of like groping at physics to make
sense of ineffable thing so psychedelics
warp space-time and you go into other
dimensions and the whole thing but I
wonder like what you make of like an end
of a film like that because could they
both be true could it have been a
space-time thing when the aliens are
what exists and the other dimensions of
consciousness or did you hallucinate the
whole thing or is it like it's a
material thing is it a poetic truth is
it a religious truth of the church is
the state like how do you out of you
grapple well I mean I'm comfortable with
the idea that that part of reality that
there are edges of reality whatever I'm
going to leave it momentarily undefined
that our anomalous that there are
anomalies that anomalies are part of
reality now that doesn't mean that the
anomaly is pointing to necessarily a
whole other order of existence so if we
look at the 15 hours on the camera as an
anomaly that shouldn't have been there
we just saw her go through there that's
an anomaly what do we do with it and my
attitude is that even if you're able to
kind of explain away certain anomalies
eventually they're just going to keep
coming so it's less about that certain
anomalies are pointing towards a certain
story
oh there's actually this other dimension
that does this and that that to me is a
little bit of a wild goose chase and
that more to the point is that anywhere
we look
for really paying attention we're gonna
see some anomalies mmm whether it's in
fairy lore whether it's in prophetic
dreams whether it's in you know it's
like these things are there they're like
spark you know scattered throughout and
they I think that they are there to
always remind us of the limitations of
our given reality construct that there's
cracks in the construct but that sort of
letting the crack just you know sort of
erode your total conviction in your
worldview is probably more important
than attempting to see through it to get
to exactly the next order of the
explanation and that just tends to be
the way that I react to those kinds of
kinds of things there's another
interesting thing about contact if I
remember correctly is that they're
trying to build the machine in the
States but there's a crazy Christian
yeah who like blows impaired or whatever
yeah and then we go to the east yeah and
there's a shot of Jodie Foster in her
hotel room in the back you see an N so
which is the Zen Buddhist circle that
sort of means emptiness or nothing Oh
interesting so even though Makani is you
know clearly a Christian preacher guy
there's also a critique of like the God
concept and it's almost like you have to
go through this kind of Buddhist notion
of emptiness no God nothing holy to get
to the encounter and I thought that was
a really interesting a little bit a bit
bit of the movie that that reminds me of
when you wrote about the matrix and you
talk about the neo melting into the
mirror and undergoing the mystic
psychotic collapse and then having to
walk in the bardos in before the world
that recreates itself like the bardos
after the pixellating wake of like fully
dematerializing or disappearing or dying
and then being in the bar of the nothing
before something else emerges I mean it
seems like that's a pretty interesting
yeah everything and I think that that's
related to this idea of the crack mm-hmm
you know is like oh it's just a
construct can we just stay with it's
just a construct instead of going
immediately to well it's a
because these other forces are creating
this other story and behind the
construct is this other order of power
and this is what's actually happening
everybody wants to go there what does it
mean to just be like wow it's a
construct the rug I'm standing on is on
nothing yeah and that's it be in that
moment you know the example that I'm
thinking of this is this is something
I've been like kind of practicing for a
while I was like yeah I like to seek
naps I like to do what my wife Jennifer
dumper calls the liminal dreaming
meaning like to kind of surf on the
edges of awaking you know awaken and
asleep going kind of into this beginning
of the dream realm but I'm not quite
asleep and you just kind of play with
that a lot and one of the things I've
been a bit I've been teaching myself is
when you you wake up from a nap
I mean wake up anyplace but you know or
if you're traveling or whatever it
happens a lot you know there's a little
moment you don't know where you are once
in a while it happened right wasn't very
rarely but it was really very scary one
time it happened I was very afraid yes
so what I actually had to think really
I'm not wrong right but but I what I've
taught myself to do is when I have that
including that shock instead of trying
to figure it out
I just remain in the not knowing where I
am and it just boom it just explodes
it's a very beautiful strange intimacy
with this not knowing which is just one
of my big themes whether I'm talking
about mystery whether I'm talking about
well we don't we can't really say what
the cosmic metaphysical reality is
beyond these experiences or whether I'm
pointing out the way the different
accounts of reality smash into each
other and we can't really determine
between them is is not a kind of not
knowing where you throw up your hands
and we you stop trying to explain things
it's really becoming comfortable and
intimate with the everyday experience of
mystery of being awake of sitting across
the table from the others and
recognizing that nobody really
ultimately knows what's going on but at
least we're having a really good
conversation we're having a really good
time we're working on it you know what I
mean and
like quote that says like something like
we're all falling through space nobody
knows what the [ __ ] is going on but the
good news there is no ground and I
wonder sometimes ok fine look there's
ineffable mysteries or there's things
that can be there's things that can be
can we F to be difficult yeah there's
things that can be dickin deconstructed
and there's things that can be explained
like you know when I watch a movie I
know ok this is 24 frames per second
creates the illusion of motion
you know these actors have memorized
these lines this has been edited
together into a sequence of events that
I can only make sense of because it
operates the way my consciousness does
right attention represents the close-up
foreboding represents future projection
flashbacks represent the memory of the
past and that cinema is actually
consciousness meets its own process when
we watch movies and the reason that we
can have those experiences because it
mimics interior tea more than empirical
reality and so we then understanding
that tells me it's like okay so we
actually are
we're dual in our beingness we exist in
a consensus like empirical reality to
the degree that we can manipulate it so
that airplanes take off and land and
communicate with each other and
Shannon's theory of information makes it
so that I can freakin do [ __ ]
FaceTime calls with the device made of
plastic and metal and the other car
whatever like there are mysterious
things that we can still account for in
that outside world but then there are
interior experiences like my
consciousness encountering a Chris Nolan
film when I'm a little bit stoned in the
theater and I'm having a profoundly
church-like mythological Joseph Campbell
ask out of time transfigure ating
experience that's eating my
consciousness with great truths that are
gonna then affect my behavior in the
world Shh adjust my baseline and how I
feel about life in general like like and
that I make friends enough with those
two sides those two modalities the the a
deeply spiritual religious mythical
interior life and with a grounding in an
external reality that is infinitely
complicated
- you know airplanes that fly and
smartphones that video conference and
our voice turning into electrical
molecules being recorded by these camera
they're that and that's also true and
that they're both true but they're they
just they're just like it's an analogy
you could draw from physics Newtonian
physics on one scale relativity physics
on another scale quantum physics on
another scale and different rules emerge
on different scales so you could also
argue the different rules or principles
or set of behaviors emerge in different
modes so we could sort of borrow that
consolation from physics I'm like well
it's just different on different scales
how about like reality is just different
between different different modes I mean
yeah what are you yeah I mean I'm trying
to find some kind of peace or resolution
maybe there isn't any no no I mean
that's that's part of it is that we you
know the the is to grow comfortable with
the possibility that we are in a zone
within which multiple modes are
operating and that our desire that's
based on science that's based on the way
our brains work with based on language
or whatever to unify them or to dominate
them with a particular story is is is
going to be so challenged by the nature
of the situation that it's much better
to learn to ask to bring the appropriate
tool to the appropriate domain to
recognize that all domains are not one
they're not oh there they overlap yeah
they interact sure there's it's not like
a you know a sky high wall Ryan II means
right sure you know there's but
sometimes sometimes I can get high on
cannabis and have a really good time and
then start feeling a little anxious in
the trip and then I realize I really
have to pee yeah yeah that would be an
example of literally that happening like
the domain of physical reality and me
having a bladder that's full of urine
that needs to go pee is is spilling over
into the into the tray into the dream
world very similar to the movie
Inception plays with that metaphor does
where it's like you can be dreaming and
if they pour water on you while you're
in the dream it starts to rain so
there's bleed-through effects between
the modes right and so accounting for
that allows you to steward the
experience you have in each of the modes
right and then also to not become
completely absorbed into any of them for
example you can have your transcendental
experience at the Hollywood cinema but
there's you know sometimes there's
arguments to be made that you know that
those experiences are themselves part of
a larger machinery of distraction that
is very consciously deployed in order to
keep a lot of our minds occupied oh yeah
give them their Joseph Campbell you know
here with a thousand faces
Sherlock to keep them all obsessed and
in these little circuits of media so
they're not actually asking questions
about other things that are going on now
I'm not saying you shouldn't you know
reap you know mythological and sacred
data or inspiration from wherever you
can get it but there's also reasons to
be to question the places that society
has elected for church to happen and to
bring the state or to ask state like
questions in in that church and on the
other side to go into the state thing
and to go okay where's the sacred here
where's the myth operating here what are
these
yeah myths in this other zone so that's
also part of the key but it's not
collapsing them into one it's just
recognizing that we're constantly
negotiating the the borderline between
various modes and to try to become
someone who is comfortable with that
100% you know we're gonna wrap it up
soon because I want to respect your time
but you know hearing everything and from
the beginning this conversation has been
about modes the inside and the outside
the poetic and the empirical subjective
truth objective truth consensus reality
and your own reality your own experience
church and state and the analogy of like
you know government works better when we
separate church and state until we'd
have to make sure that we keep our modes
separate but knowing that they
occasionally bleed into each other and I
would go so far as to say that you
to ative Lee I think I've that's been my
way of resolving existential angst as
much as possible for now you know we'll
see when I'm 80 years old and I have to
I can no longer deny one of the modes
but but for now look I know that I need
to eat three times a day I know that I
need to go to the bathroom and
metabolize food I know that I need to
lie down in a bed eight hours and
[ __ ] go to sleep you know like there
are things that are non-negotiable in
one mode in fact they're nourishing
sleep and food are nourishing but what's
also equally necessary and nourishing
for me is to have mythopoetic and
aesthetically oriented nourishment so I
need to listen to music that makes me
cry I need to disappear or lose track of
my own boundaries when I watch a movie I
need experiences of absolute immersion
or absolute unmixed attention when Wilde
calls which is a form of Prayer you know
where I disappear you know Diana
Slattery's idea that all inter personal
transformation education or persuasion
takes place when you are completely
absorbed in something and so for me the
mythopoetic is a chance to surrender all
agency into some constructs some
aesthetic constructs that will carry me
away towards ecstatic catharsis and
communion as Jamie wheel says and that
as long as I know what I need I'm okay
do you know what I'm saying in both
modes no what you need in every mode and
I feel like that's the way of finding
like the closest thing you can to
harmony yeah anything mister and I think
that's also just part it was like you do
it too cuz with all you grapple how come
you're not a paranoid mess like with all
you grapple your basic disposition and
demeanor is like hey bro yeah you're
you're chill yeah no I cuz I have a lot
of practices behind me because I pay a
lot of attention to to food to diet to
exercise to meditation to yoga to you
know reading and listening to those
things that inspire me or that allow me
to move through that so I you know my
what I do intellectually or in terms of
my expression is
part of the way that I navigate my life
and I don't really think of myself as
the guy who's thinking all these things
you know I'm this other guy who does all
this who has this life and I'm doing all
these things and whatever in a
relationship you know having really
working on that and you know it's it's
easier now when I was younger I was much
much more
you know angsty way more angsty very you
know anxious worried depressed you know
I you know the full gamut of you know
yeah
sensitive neurology kind of approach and
but I took that as a encouragement to
develop practices that would enable me
to be being more steady to develop my
own kind of center of gravity so for if
we're both you know if we're if we're
all just falling through the void and
there's no ground well there is
something like a center of gravity that
you carry that's you know you learn that
if you're like running down the
mountainside you know you're like wait
how am I not just falling apart well
because I'm actually kind of moving it
with my own body you do Tai Chi you're
like moving your energy center around
your center of gravity and so there's a
way of living that way too without the
expectation of totally solid ground and
yet being grounded in your practice and
even in the regularity of practice and
yeah and though and what that gives you
so there's a whole other side of me
where I could just be talking about
meditation and practices or whatever and
I've just chosen to not you know I'm
talking about it more now than I then I
used to but but it's taken me a long
time I mean I mean I'm in my 50s and you
know it's gotten better way better but
it took a long time you know when I was
a young person it was much more
challenging to be me mm-hmm
interesting yeah well yeah I mean it
feels like in the end there's gotta be
this intention of for whatever it is I'm
gonna make it I'm gonna make it work for
me
you know I'm gonna come up with a way of
making it making it work for me you know
like as long as the the keep the
neurosis at bay have rationalizations
that are useful but not pathological
stay somewhat open but remain grounded
have flights of fancy but make sure you
eat so you don't have a manic episode
like you know it's like make it
can work for you and and I hope that
people can develop those intuitive
muscles to you know to figure out a way
how to play their note you know yeah
great
Eric Davis thank you all right sir it
was great dude any closing remarks or
places you want to send your our
audience to tech gnosis comm yeah I mean
I still just crank it out there and you
know hi weirdness is gonna be out in
paperback in September and it's doing
really well people people like it's it's
it's a [ __ ] it's challenging but
rewarding so you know if you like a
challenge that's rewarding it's it's
probably for you but I mean so so I'm
just still talking about that and just
one more question cuz I just remembered
I wanted to ask you this where do you
stand on synchronicity I got this this
can oh that's full of worms oh that
could be for part no no here I'll give
you brief no yes so I'll just throw
through okay you wrote an essay on
burning man that I loved called beyond
belief and you talked about the
demolition derby of reality constructs
colliding on a parched void he talked
about pocket universes and the
juxtaposition of those pocket universes
you talked about evanescent lightning
bolts of meaning in the perceivers mind
and then finally I'll never forget this
you said that the juxtaposition is the
formal operating space of synchronicity
yes and now you synchronicity and
serendipity interchangeably so if you if
you if you like take a few minutes yeah
well just okay I'll call it closed on
this one just it came up recently with
another another conversation and what
one sort of point to make about
synchronicity is if we if we experience
them a little bit you know have one
maybe one the next day whatever it
usually feels pretty good even if
they're slightly that's ramen as' yeah
it feels like yeah there is some deeper
mystery things or I'm on the right path
or the spirits are and we go into
magical thinking we're like this we have
to we have no there's no place to avoid
a little bit of magical thinking for
sure and if it's almost like like
psychedelic gray
you know the idea of Christian grace is
that you it's nothing that you do God
gives it to you you have no control over
it it's kind of like that you have
you're sitting there you're doing your
life unlike whoa there's this remarkable
set of this event of serendipity but if
you just have those same experiences
more frequently like way more frequently
you're psychotic
yeah so and I mean I say that not to say
that synchronicity is an indication of
psychosis
at all it's that with vit with
synchronicity as well as so many other
domains of altered states and marginal
forms of consciousness and spiritual
this and trance that and magic this and
all that kind of stuff is there it's a
spectrum and in some ways it's a
spectrum at the far end of which is
psychosis or other forms of extreme
mental distress right but without beat
without investigating that spectrum I
think our lives are incredibly dry right
and and also people don't have to worry
about that spectrum being there because
a spectrum is is can be you can have a
range enough to almost be like a change
in kind yeah you know like water turning
into vapor there's a spectrum but then
there's a temperature when water turns
into vapor so there's still the same
material molecule so to speak so I would
say that it's very similar in that
spectrum you know yeah people shouldn't
worry if there's the right amount of
synchronicity irregular time that
they're psychotic but certainly when
somebody's doing way too many
psychedelics and then they become
convinced that they are Jesus Christ and
then they end up in a psych ward you
know that's when connecting the dots
when when seeing more patterns becomes
pattern isset II Isaiah Berlin to
understand it to perceive patterns right
but seeing too many patterns everywhere
when everything is meaningful
well now you're psychotic right that's
that's it so you're you're it's always
walking a tightrope you know it's always
a balancing act it's always a middle
path you know and then the other thing
to say about synchronicities that I
think is really important to is to is to
focus it's the same kind of message I've
been saying it's to focus on the actual
phenomenological experience of
encountering the sense the in deeply
intuitive powerful sense that there's
some other
order of reality or meaning but don't
attempt to understand what that other
order of reality actually might mean
that's partly the way that you build a
psychotic response and instead
synchronicities are both revelations and
veiling x' at the same time because
they're pointing to some other order
reality that's orchestrating all this
but you don't get to see that other
order of reality all you see is the
orchestration and to me that's what it
is it's the simultaneity of this
revelation with a veiling Wow what's
that in your pipe is can't two people
have any agency over creating more
conditions for synchronicity well George
George Carlin talks about psycho
cybernetics you know like priming your
brain thinking something writing it down
reading what you've written the middle
oh sudden you see it everywhere and so
you can prime your brain to heighten
serendipity to get you achieved to
achieve your goals because the brain is
a pattern seeking machine galore so it's
like it's like well play with the
program like play with the revelation
and the veiling to suit your needs in
the world as long as the needs are
additive to the community and to the
planet and you know allow you to make a
contribution that's burning mint for
those I was gonna say you see or you set
up environments like Burning Man where
there's a lot of material that a lot of
room for random juxtaposition a lot of
room for resonance and overtones we pile
on associations you know there's the
whole space is like a cannabis
Association machine where everything is
connected with everything else so then
you're gonna have more of those kinds of
experiences I think that's partly why
cognitively it's so refreshing to go to
festivals it's not just we have fun or
that we press our boundaries or that we
can socialize in a kind of quasi utopian
space where we can leave a lot of the
normal [ __ ] aside I think it's also
cognitively stimulating and refreshing
to sort of be an environment where these
things are kind of happening without or
without our will or you know we set them
in motion in that way so I think that's
a
that's a really can be a very tasty way
of nourishing yeah that side of
ourselves that needs that scent of magic
needs that church man
it needs that church to forever do you
mind if I just so share one more
anecdote
it's about cannabis and you know Michael
Pollan in the beginning of his book how
to change your mind says that one of the
nice things about cannabis as a tool and
I would say a tool for an entry point
for the more church like mythopoetic
realms is that it he says and his beauty
and travel can do this - is that it
knocks all signals forwards and
backwards
the automatic thing that the brain does
of taking data from the present
comparing it with data from the past and
using that to predict the future been
there isn't seen Bad's of the adult mind
and that cannabis through its short-term
memory disruption and breaking the flow
of time and to discrete present moments
knocks all signals forwards and
backwards dropping you into the flow of
the present a present that is literally
Wonder - full because wonder is the
byproduct of that unencumbered sense of
first sight to which the adult brain is
typically closed itself and the
unencumbered sense of first sight you
can only have if your brain can't recall
exactly what this is like or what it is
gonna be and so you're encountering the
world with a virginal noticing and so
when you put yourself in that state
you're highly suggestible and highly
malleable to stimuli because your
defenses are down and your your quick
leap frogging to the future into the
conclusion and so in the combination of
something like cannabis with a festival
with a movie with listening to music you
know with with toolkits and/or
constructions around you that also are
working with the cannabis to create a
portal into the church into the the
sacred or the the poetic I just think
it's a great tool for it and now that
it's legal it's just like as long as
people can keep those lines and modes
divided what a great what a great little
lubricant yeah to facilitate and yeah
I've been really interested in in in
exploring the overlap between
cannabis and meditation small doses of
canton of cannabis just a little bit to
sort of allow that zone in and what what
it supports and what it doesn't support
from like a more serious straight
meditation kind of perspective and one
of the places it supports I believe is
precisely in the ability to be present
to phenomenological flow States and for
me you know I know that if I get stone
and go see a crappy science fiction
movie I'm gonna have all sorts of Marvel
marvelous experiences like even that
that whole thing about contact earlier
with the Christian and then yeah so like
I was stoned so I was like oh man it's
like yeah oh it's the Zen verse okay you
know like but it's really no it's in the
movie but it's sort of not you know
whatever its associational thing
probably the director might not have
thought about it at all doesn't matter
but I find much more satisfying and more
church like is really just the ability
to be in the present flow of a moment
with just ordinary sensation I mean I'm
very zen that way so I recall in
particular one time where I was
listening I was at the beach understand
a Barbara it was night and we were
stoned and my friends were off doing
something else and I just sat there and
I listened to the waves crashing and I
was particularly noting the way that you
know as the waves crash it's it's sort
of it really defines the sort of space
of sound because it's over here in the
left part of the field and then it it
traces a line over here to the right and
then it just does it again and I became
aware that that by being in the space of
sound and then allowing this event to
take place through the space it was
almost like I was surfing it because I
was actually kind of writing my
attention was riding the line of this
marvelous rich sound of all these
overtones and qualities and I was out
absolutely absorbed
there was no thought of anything else
I'm not hungry I don't need a beer I'm
not what am I gonna do tomorrow and you
know and so my experience cannabis can
really support those things for a
certain period of time correct and then
there's there's ways in which it
distorts and kind of lacks clarity so
that you can't kind of always oh yeah
yeah I can't get back and now I'm back
in or the munchies it's like course it
doesn't give you the whole thing but it
gives you these moments or these little
these passages that are worth the price
of admission for build my whole life but
but very stewarded yeah because I just
like music is a structured envelope of
sound
I'm innately I'm a director like so
innately I soon as I realize I became
aware that this is a tool that makes me
more suggestible it also means that I
can steward really well thought of
structured input signals when I'm in
those suggestible States because then I
can bypass my brains been theirs and
seen that and I can hurl myself into
delightful mind/body states of hyper
presence which normally is very hard for
me yeah and so that's really nice
because it's like once I'm there I know
how to get there I know how to pick the
place how to pick the right people how
to do all the things that when you
remind me like you're creative in
linguistic choices shape your experience
and that's the first thing you notice
when you're in an altered state you're
like oh I love how this song makes me
feel oh I love the company this person
oh man this landscape is so inspiring
isn't it I'm like oh that also means
that I have agency by picking this
person and picking this song and picking
this environment like oh I can I can
construct these types of flows in the
present very intentionally and that's
nice because it's like I've made my own
church with my own rituals there you go
anyway thanks brother all right man she
ate you man thank you treat what a treat